blood bonds gameplay is unfolding before
us get it because the site is unfolding
anyway the game is being played on the
show floor of Gamescom where a new
trailer was also shown and there's a lot
of news flying around from different
publications so there's lots we can chat
about first up weaponry and offense so
if you've played a souls game you know
how important weapons are in most games
weapons reflect your character you know
you'll SPECT a certain way so you choose
daggers or a fast weapon but in souls
games I think it's the other way around
your weapon takes center stage and it
defines the character and the way you
play in blood-borne this is no different
in fact I'd argue that it takes it to
the next level so with a gun in our left
hand and a melee weapon in our right we
identify as one of the hunters stalking
the streets of yharnam we've just
learned that pressing l1 on your
controller will alter the state of your
held melee weapon so what was once a
short one-handed hatchet that was
designed for use in narrow corridors
could become an elongated two-handed
scythe for dealing with foes at a
distance with the press of a button you
change the range damage look and feel of
one weapon essentially doubling your
arsenal of attacks this is really cool I
keep watching this transformation of the
scythe over and over again once more
detail you see in this clip is that the
player actually elongates the blade
during a swing adding the range he needs
to hit another enemy this is really cool
stuff it just adds so much depth to the
game moving on to your left hand if you
have a gun in that hand then l2 will
simply fire that gun and we've been told
that there are a range of firearms but
the only ones we've seen so far are the
shotgun style weapons and you might be
thinking these guns they're gonna be so
overpowered they're just going to rip
through any enemy I shoot but I think
you'd be wrong because from what I
understand we won't be using guns in
that way for one thing ammunition is
going to be apparently deliberately
limited for another thing players of
blood-borne noted that guns aren't
actually primarily used for damage
they're used to stun so you fire a grape
shot at an enemy and they'll flinch for
about half
and you go up to that enemy and you
press r1 while he's stunned and you
perform a critical attack this teaches
us that guns are a method of crowd
control you know just like you parry
someone they go into a repo stable state
well now when you shoot someone it
appears that they will go into that same
state and there a method of initiating
criticals and a method of crowd control
so far we haven't actually seen them
used to deal a lot of damage to
opponents which I'm sure is really
reassuring for a lot of you and one
thing I find really interesting is that
guns are now apparently a staple part of
the gameplay just like shields would be
every player apparently seems like
they're going to be going through the
game with a gun in their left hand
the gun is usurping that traditional
slot of a shield and it just seems like
it reflects that offensive style of
gameplay that we're going to see our one
with a melee weapon performs a simple
series of slashes just like you're used
to
r2 is still a slow strong attack but
it's a little bit different this time
around
by holding down r2 you can charge the
attack presumably performing more damage
the longer you charge it according to a
few sites that I read this charge up
attack can also be used to stun enemies
much like I just explained before with
the gun this will put them into a
riposte able animation where you can
perform a critical attack so that'll be
really interesting to see I think it
also depends on your positioning a few
sites were saying that if you do the
charge up attack behind an enemy it
could initiate a critical so but we'll
have to wait and see I don't know
exactly anyway speaking of controls the
circle button is still your designated
dodge button but it's also a bit
different this time around tapping it
when you're locked on will make your
character - around an enemy much faster
than a roll wood tapping it when
unlocked apparently also allows you to
perform a roll so you have rolls when
you're unlocked and you have dashes when
you're locked on as you guys can tell
from all this all the controls seem like
they're changing really subtly but you
know a soules veteran will still be able
to get used to them but the smallest
changes like these could have a huge
effect on the way combat works a good
example of these subtle changes is the
triangle button so pressing the triangle
button will now
he'll your character which brings us on
to healing the brand-new Estes is
something called a blood vial and
assumedly it works almost identically to
the way Estes did except now we have a
dedicated button for this heal and the
charges are now visible in the top left
so what does this mean well it can be
assumed that they want you to be aware
of this healing potential at all times
this implies that we'll be taking more
damage and that there might also be more
emphasis on knowing how much healing you
have remaining one of the things I
dislike about Dark Souls 2 is the fact
that you can stock up on life gems and
the fact that they're putting one
element of healing center stage implies
that blood vials might be more valuable
yes just just was not as valuable in
Dark Souls 2 as it was in Dark Souls 1
because you know the addition of life
gems means you can heal between battles
so the fact that they're putting blood
vials centerstage makes me a bit more
excited about healing the only thing we
don't know is how we replenish blood
files
I assume it's going to be the same as in
Dark Souls where you can just rest it up
on fire to replenish your Estus or blood
file simply because we know that a
checkpoint system similar to bonfires
still exists in blood-borne but blood
vials aren't the only way to heal nope
there's another way to heal and it's one
of the most exciting things about
blood-borne because to me it really
reflects the new style of play so in
Dark Souls you're encouraged to have a
defensive approach to combat you know
you have to have your shield up you have
to wait for enemies to make a move you
have to block then attack that's a
really defensive way of playing going
without a shield in Dark Souls makes the
game harder for example in blood-borne
this isn't the case and they're building
in ways to reward the player for being
more offensive and taking more risks and
being more Rambo you know one such
method is the new health through gained
system so this is a system that rewards
players for taking more risks and being
more decisive and strategic in their
offensive abilities the regain system
allows players to recover health lost
after taking damage and this is achieved
by striking back at enemies within a
short time period with a bladed weapon
so let me explain imagine you take
damage instead of losing the
health immediately the damage you took
is shown off as yellow in the HP Gorge
and will deplete over time if you
hesitate to strike if you hit back while
you're still losing this yellow health
then your health will stop depleting
from the damage you took so basically
when you get hit you have two options a
you can accept that you're going to lose
that health and keep playing safely or B
you can run the risk of going even more
offensive after you've taken damage
running the risk of replenishing the
health you lost or taking even more
damage than you took in the first place
this means that you'll have to be smart
and strategic with your strikes as some
offensive play could actually result in
you getting more health back I love this
at the core of the game is this idea
that every encounter could be your last
Miyazaki has said multiple times that he
wants the player to be wary as he stalks
the streets and he wants there to be
this feeling of struggle that's what he
said with this new healing system he's
managed to incorporate this idea of
tension and risk and reward mechanically
into the game this guy's a genius in
every encounter you're actually going to
be struggling against your enemies to
take their life from them and you're
going to be encouraged to risk
recovering some of your own life if
you're playing aggressive and confident
like the devs want you to and hey I'm
the king of segues because speaking of
struggle let's move on to the supposed
difficulty of the game hey guys do you
remember when Dark Souls 2 was still
being announced and a developer said
Dark Souls 2 is going to be accessible
well back then that ended up being a
mistranslation here we go again
according to an article from said that
one of their focuses with this game is
and I quote not focusing over much on
punishing the player and that they want
to attract a wider audience and as to be
expected with the Internet lots of
people immediately lost their [ __ ] and
proclaimed that blood-borne was going to
be a casual title I don't think it's
going to be a casual title because if
you read a little bit more than that
title of the clickbait article then you
realize that from also said that they
don't plan on making compromises that
will
and the difficulty loving fanbase they
know that there's value in a system that
punishes you but also rewards you they
go on to say that they want to maintain
this emphasis on achievement reward and
overcoming seemingly impossible
challenges but the thing is they want to
do it in different ways than just with
making the game incredibly difficult
there's more of an emphasis on tension
this time around so just like with Dark
Souls 2 let's wait and see
Before we jump to conclusions because
there's just no way we can know how
difficult the games going to be I know a
lot of you are interested in PvP and
co-op so let's talk about how the online
interaction of the game is going to work
so if we use Sun Bros out there they've
said nothing about how co-op is going to
work except that it's going to
definitely be there so that's good to
know
I can imagine a small band of hunters
teaming up to take on the night so that
is an image I like and that is something
I'm really looking forward to PvP is
also going to play a part so we don't
have many confirmed PvP details but we
do have a few clues number one they're
looking to make some kind of seamless
multiplayer where instead of ghosts
you're going to interact with real
players take this as you will but I
interpret it personally to mean that
will seamlessly enter other people's
worlds rather than actively invade like
a passive form of PvP rather than an
active one but what do you guys think
personally I think it's going to be more
fights that are like being summoned for
the mirror night in Dark Souls 2 where
your PvP interaction is contextual where
we become the boss battle or we find
ourselves fighting alongside each other
against a boss you know that kind of
context your PvP might be really
interesting I have no idea how this is
going to work yet but it's interesting
to keep in mind so this aspect of
contextual PvP might also play into
another clue that they gave us and that
is that apparently another important
aspect of the game is hunting beasts
players this sounds cool we know that
village people are transforming into
beasts that's the nature of the
infection that's blood-borne but does
this mean that we can turn into beasts
and
play as a beast it sounds like it people
are transforming into werewolves into
beasts they have these elongated limbs
and fur and they look much more like
animals a few people have speculated
that the more blood you ingest the more
beasts like you become so turning into
beasts using that in PvP somehow keep
your eye out for more details on that
topic moving on to level design as we
wrap up previous reports have stated
that levels will have a high level of
verticality as you move through them
which basically means multiple ways to
tackle a level and I just want to
reiterate that here many reports from
the show floor at Gamescom have told us
that people are experiencing level
design similar to that of Dark Souls
where the level is consistently complex
rather than linear in one direction so
that's really good news in the DLC for
Dark Souls 2 even we're seeing more
complex level design and I am all for
that that's something we saw way more in
Dark Souls and Demon's Souls this is
something that Miyazaki likes doing
apparently
and speaking of Miyazaki he's also
talked a lot about the atmosphere of
blood-borne and the legend himself has
said that he wants to capture the tone
of the Tower of latria from Demon Souls
which if you've played Demon Souls
you know why I'm excited for this I mean
when I go back to Demon Souls I
literally feel chilled at the thought of
playing that zone again it's one of
those levels in a game that just makes
you go ah I have to tackle this again
and you know you'll know what I'm
talking about if you've played it before
I go here's a few other tidbits that I
couldn't walk into the script before
this point if you're still interested
so character customization still exists
as the same way in the souls series
stats will make a return and they'll be
similar to the souls series but they'll
incorporate some new ideas the death
penalty will still exist in a similar
capacity where we retrieve our souls
upon death but apparently we aren't
retrieving souls anymore there hasn't
really been any mention of souls
so what are we retrieving we're still
going to lose something upon
we just don't know what it is yet next
is that there's still a checkpoint
system in the game so think bonfires
from Dark Souls also you'll notice in
all these clips that the UI has a much
more uncluttered design and more
information is showing up top left I
like this I reckon it gives you more of
a view of things that are happening on
the screen and since they're pushing
this really aggressive style of gameplay
I think it's even more important than it
was in Dark Souls to make sure that the
actions and attacks of enemies and
players on screen needs to be much more
clear so I'm really happy that they're
pushing stuff over to the top left of
the screen if you're more interested in
the story or the setting of blood-borne
then I've got a video on that too so you
should check that out other than that I
hope you enjoyed the video feel free to
Kindle the channel if you're feeling
generous and I'll see you guys next time
thank you so much for watching okay
before I go this isn't really related to
the gameplay but at the end of the clip
the trailer we saw we here the maiden in
black's voice actor speak and man am I
excited to hear that she's in the game
that voice actor is amazing and the
nostalgia that comes with her voice will
add a really good quality to this game
so I'm keen for that and you just had to
say that ok bye